i want to be able to pick where i get to
live and pick what kind of car i want
and pick what i do throughout the day
when i became famous i started to
believe that i was
this terrible evil just
tyrant just the whole antichrist what
are you like in a relationship
i am a good girlfriend i would
definitely say i'm a good girlfriend
can't nobody do it like me like me
you have this new song and video out um
it's called do it like me
it's been viewed over 1.7 million times
how does that feel when you hear that i
mean i've been hearing this since i was
like 13 that my song had been doing
crazy so
i'm kind of used to it at this point but
it still feel good
i'm not the same little badass kid i was
when i was like five years ago so
a lot of people like oh i actually like
her now oh there's really nothing wrong
with her oh like you know i'm saying so
why do you think people are suddenly
having this change of heart and
understanding that
you're an artist i feel like because
everyone expected me to just be around
for like five minutes and just disappear
so i feel like they're kind of like oh
we can't push her
out okay we might as well just accept it
and she actually isn't that bad
so do you feel like you had to
prove yourself over these past few years
because of that
i don't feel like i necessarily
had to but i just by me being me it just
showed like
there's something wrong with me okay i
just run around with a gun and a knife
trying to kill people all day like
when i would do interviews it'd be like
oh i was scared you were gonna hit me or
something it would just be like
what why would i just come into a room
and hit you you ain't never met a [ __ ]
like me before got a whole lot of drip
in the bank
to the top where you can't go ain't got
no time what is the status of the album
i'm
just working i nothing's really
fully put together yet so in your dream
world
what does the album sound like probably
just
a lot of
just me type songs because i'm tired of
label music you know i'm saying like
labels
push to have things put out that the
artist doesn't want or that they just
think it's catchy
and it's it's never about oh let's do
what the artist wants
it's always about let's do what the
label wants so if it was in my favor i'd
want everything to be my way with
in your mind what like what is your
place in the music industry i guess
um i just do music that's it i just
i don't i'm just iris i don't really
know how to explain my
place amazing like collaborated with
some really cool people in the past
megan the stallion
comes to mind could we ever get another
collaboration
yeah i would i would work with megan
again yeah you're turning 18
in a few months right like six months
what are you looking forward to most
about turning 18 and does it feel like a
new chapter for you
probably like i'm really just gonna be
putting my foot down like there's a lot
of people
in my circle who think that they can
control me because i'm young i'mma let
it be known like this is what we're
doing
no one's telling you to leave no one's
telling you to stay i'm telling you this
is what we're doing and if you don't
like it you can leave if you like it you
can stay
but i'm not gonna have anybody around me
who thinks that just because i'm
under 21 you can sit here and tell me
how i'm gonna do it what color i'm gonna
do it with and like you know what i'm
saying like all that you're not gonna
tell me what i'm doing
is that from a creative standpoint like
a friendship standpoint
family from everything
from family to management to label all
that
like basically just i want to be able to
pick where i get to live and pick what
kind of car i want and pick what i do
throughout the day
just regular stuff regular stuff that i
shouldn't have to ask for
not even just because i'm famous or just
because it's only because i'm young
and the people who have been around me
have been around me since i was 13.
so the boundary has already been crossed
and there's no coming back from that
yeah it's just oh we're gonna lie to her
and tell her things to
to to get her upset so that she doesn't
want what we want her to do
it's really just like it's a sick mind
game honestly they just have these
bad ways of trying to trick me
if that makes sense because people think
i need to be tricked into doing things
when i really would just do things if i
was just
people were honest with me so i'll be
damned if i let some
manager or some some head of the label
or some anything like that
tell me how i'm going to live my whole
life
for a while i couldn't wear the clothes
i wanted to wear
do you fear ever like them
dropping you oh i don't care i'll be out
the door
i don't care at all the art is more
important than the politics
yeah i do want to say i'm so proud of
you
for seeking treatment i know how hard
that can be
but i read that it was for prescription
drug use but also for
childhood trauma what was the moment
when you knew that you needed help
and how are you doing i've always just
kind of blocked
i don't really want to say block things
out i just i feel like it just i never
think about things like i
anything that happened when i was a kid
i just don't think about it but you know
subconsciously you act a certain way
due to things that have happened you
know what i'm saying so i'm not
understanding why i'm acting like this
i'm just
acting and i really had to sit down and
and think about
well where's where's the starting point
and it's hard when the starting point is
all the way
buried under some more some more it's
more
it's hard to to figure it out so i had
to
go somewhere where i could unravel and
feel safe about unraveling you know what
i'm saying
yeah and and the sad part is
when when you're when you're working
with people who who don't have
nothing to lose and who just like you
know kids in there who
who don't have like i said don't have
nothing to lose they don't make millions
of dollars they don't have a
i have a hundred people i mean a million
people watching them they don't have to
abide by
the hipaa launch like that they can go
tell their friends if they want to it's
still hard
you know what i'm saying you know that
these people who work here can't wait to
go home and tell their kids
guess who i've seen today at work you
know even though there's a hippo law
and even though they signed mbas and all
that you know they're still gonna do it
i was just telling my mom this earlier i
mean yesterday if you make a
a a bum sign nba and i mean nba and then
you make
kylie jenner sign nba probably a better
chance that kylie's gonna abide by that
then the bum is because if you sue the
bum hey you like look at
him anyway it still is still hard to
feel comfortable but at that point you
just gotta say hey what happens happens
what what do you feel like you learned
about yourself
and treatment and how have you grown or
changed as a person
well when when i became famous
i started to believe that i was this
terrible
evil just tyrant just the whole
antichrist is really what i believe
because it's like
yeah you don't want to listen to haters
but the same way if you
if you get a certain hairstyle and
people are messing with you like oh
that's that's the cute hair like messing
with you like oh
that's funny looking they're like oh
just playing you're still gonna believe
it because you're gonna be like well why
would you
you know it takes for someone to say
something like when people be like oh
i'm just joking i used to think like
that like oh well if people are really
saying
and that the fact that they're all
saying the same thing it's not like
one's like her eyes ugly
her hair is ugly her shoe her this or
that it's they're all
saying the same thing and about your
character
yeah and it's and i'm so young it's like
what else are you gonna believe the same
way if you tell it
you could tell a kid that this is a bowl
since they're since they're a baby if
you tell them that this is a bowl
they're going to believe that because
they don't know no better
and me being so young and having all
these people telling me this stuff
yes i was why are you laughing at me
oh my mom was trying to open a door with
a corona bottle all the way into her
mouth i don't know how she's trying to
hold it up like she made it
who who is my mom
so that's like i said if you tell them
something that's all they're gonna know
do you have a better view of yourself
now then
yeah a lot of people think that oh once
you're rich and famous you
you're good you don't need that you
don't need to have any good mental
health you don't have to
take care of yourself you don't have to
have good people around you if anything
is worse as a regular it's like you miss
the normal things of life you you miss
the things that you shouldn't have to
ask for
i cannot get in my car and go to the gas
station and pick up some
gummy bears i can't do it i have to
either have my boyfriend with me or my
mom with me
or somebody with me and even sometimes
if i if i go out just me and my friend
imani like if it's just like a girl with
me
i'll still be scared i know that's a bad
way to think about things but you have
to be realistic and this is the word the
sick and twisted world that we live in
are you you feel scared for your life
every time that you leave your house
no not necessarily no not
not not every time i leave my house i
was saying if i
i as being a fa and being famous at a
young age
i i lost the the freedom of being a me
and my female friends being able to just
go out
like you know what i'm saying we always
have to have a guy with us
you know what i'm saying like you
brought up mental health
and i'm just curious how you protect
your mental health and how you make sure
that
you're okay it's hard it's it's really
hard i get into these places where i'm
just like
i don't want to do this anymore like
what's the point if i i can't go on the
internet
i can't go outside i can't talk i can't
do this i can't do that
every time i explain myself my words get
twisted and flipped and everything
it feels like there's like it feels like
you're trapped in a box like there's
nowhere to push out of because every way
you push out you're just gonna go into
another
another box so it's like sometimes i
just have to tell myself like it is what
it is like
okay you're not it's not gonna kill you
people think people say aren't gonna
kill you
it's gonna hurt but it's it's not going
to take it's not going to take your
money away
but still as a young female it sucks to
know that
if if i want to go down if i want to go
down the street and go to the mall or
something
i'ma get judged the second i walk in you
said it hurts like what hurts the most
probably just when a a
huge number of people are saying the
same thing
like i can deal with the little oh she's
trying to do this or oh she wants to be
this or
she thinks she's dead oh i could deal
with all that stuff
but once it's like a a group
a huge group of people saying the same
thing
that's when it really really gets to me
because it's like where are y'all
getting this from but then i have to
remember
it is a trend to hate me that it's what
people like to do
oh who could we pick on bad baby we know
we can get a reaction out of her
it feels like to me like fame is just
like so hard for you and you've said
i kind of think about like what's the
point do you ever think about just like
quitting all of this
and moving to a remote
state and doing your own thing or is
this
listen the internet is everywhere so
there's
unless i'm going to the middle of the
desert in egypt
and you know escaping it someone's going
to know who i am
i got 17 million followers like it's
a lot of people know who i am i have
platinum plaques you mentioned your
boyfriend in our interview you did share
a picture with him who
who is he oh he's just my boyfriend
is he in the industry at all no no
how how did you guys meet like how
serious are things
um we have a mutual friend that that's
how we met and
we're we're pretty serious what's
what's his name next question
i appreciate that you want to protect
his privacy
i am curious because i think people
think of you as like a very
fiercely independent woman like what are
you like in a relationship
i am a good girlfriend i would
definitely say i'm a good girlfriend i'm
very protective i'm very
like i'm always making sure everything's
okay people in your comment section
were like asking all these questions
about who your boyfriend is and like
asking if there's an age gap
do you wanna i feel like it's it's it's
really nobody's business
if i was 15 dating a 30 year old
it's not nobody's business i just think
that it's just people waiting to say
something
that's it okay because as soon as a lot
of these girls turn 18 they run right to
the first rapper that they see
so
that and it's it's so funny to me to sit
up here and watch people
say oh well there's a three a three year
age gap between them that's disgusting
when their moms be 35 and their dads are
reaching 60.
how how much of an age gap is beyonce
and jay-z
no that's i mean i think you make up and
people are gonna fight with me about
three years
yeah and then this is the thing about me
i can't be with no seventeen-year-old
like i'm not i'm i'm i don't act like
that i'm sorry
there's there's different there's
different ways of going about different
situations
yeah if they're like not a girl like
jojo siwa
if she dated a 17 year old okay cool
people would think that's normal or uh
16 or 17. okay yeah cause she's younger
minded
i can't gain no 17 year old i'll be
bored
i feel like i'm babysitting yeah
yeah all right but it's only a three
year age gap it's not
it's not nothing out of this world i'm
about to be 18 in five months it's not
like
and this is the thing everybody want to
talk about him
when half their favorite rappers tried
to get at me
when i was 14 15 16.
so i'm not that type of person i'm not
gonna sit out here and ruin people's
lives
but i'm just saying that they're like
you know don't don't go
judging people don't don't say that
someone's a pedophile because they're
talking to someone three years younger
than them because if he was 21
and i was 18 it would be no problem this
is a little more of a fun topic but i
was going through your instagram what
should we
what should we know or what would you
tell people who who don't know about
your story
to make them change their minds honestly
there's
there's there's not like one thing it's
a
i don't i don't really know exactly
probably just you know everybody
everybody has bumps in their road and
everybody
goes through things so if you're 20
years old
talking about oh i can't believe you're
pissing by that bush
are you gonna tell me you ain't never
pissed but you ain't never had a pee and
you never pissed by a bush before
what's been the hardest part of fame
i guess for you and what what can we do
to help change that trajectory
i just want people to understand that
i'm not going to be that 14 year old
girl forever
i'm sure you're not the same person you
were when you were 14. so don't sit here
and tell me that i just went to dr
miami because my hips are getting a
little bit wider or because my boobs are
getting bigger or my nose shape is
changing or my eyebrows are going up
more i'm tired of people telling me that
i'm getting plastic surgery and i'm
doing i'm getting older i can't help it
yeah like yeah you just want people to
and then i don't have the same attitude
yes i may have felt one way about
something when i was younger
now i feel different i'm i'm a human i'm
entitled to
that are you sober now yeah i don't i
mean i really
that's the thing with the whole drug
thing it's really funny to me because i
really wasn't off drugs like that that
was something that they made it seem a
little bit more than it was
everybody has experimented everybody has
experimented for a little bit longer
but it wasn't like oh i need percocet to
survive i need it
no do you feel like this next when your
album comes out and like this debut
album like it's gonna be a new chapter
of you for people to see i hope so i
hope that's how they take it